80th place
The war starts from here
Victory conditions call for Ria's rescue
Let's record that child
Those who try to take Ria will be merciless
Magic town
tan
[music]
tandi amrar
Parrot prison
aaj Yeah yeah yeah  I know
Marc mochi
could have taken the lead, and if they had outnumbered them, they should have been able to win.
It's because Noah and
Ria, who were holding out, were fighting back with gunfire.
I'm confused, I'm just aiming for a person,
now's the time to attract
[Applause]
Girl Doctor Marc, when he reaches a critical mass, he'll be
born all at once and release him
.  Explosive power is conveyed in proportion Taisei
Doichi's fragmentation effect
does not end the killing power as a high-explosive bullet Launch
it with a finger that doesn't have sweets